20 Monate ist das her von der Hoffnung
auf Demokratie bleiben in Afghanistan
diese Bilder auch für ihre ortskräfte
und Menschen die für westliche Werte
eingestanden sind hat die
Bundesregierung damals wie heute wenig
mehr als ein ständig wiederholtes
versprechen
wir werden uns jetzt bemühen diesen
Personen die Möglichkeit zu geben nach
Deutschland zu kommen und zwar so
schnell das möglich ist beschützen auch
vor allem die Demokratie und
menschenrechtsverteidigerin die sich
dort für universelle Werte einsetzen wir
arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran alle in
Sicherheit zu bringen
Worte die hier verhallen in diesem
kleinen Apartment in Teheran stehen die
Koffer bereit unter Lebensgefahr war die
Familie hierher gereist weil in
Afghanistan keine Papiere für
Deutschland mehr ausgestellt werden
diese Woche sollte es losgehen nach
Monaten des Bangens und Wartens nach
Berlin
als mein Mann die Flugtickets abholen
wollte haben wir eine E-Mail erhalten
dass der ganze Prozess gestoppt wurde
erkannt werden wollen die junge
Frauenrechtlerin die wir Fatima nennen
und ihre Familie nicht zu groß ist die
Sorge um die Angehörigen die noch in
Afghanistan sind doch ihre Geschichte
wollen Sie uns erzählen von den
Deutschen die Sie zwecks Ausstellung des
Visums nach Teheran bestellt haben von
der kranken Mutter wegen der sie
zunächst nicht reisen konnten von den
Kindern die seit Monaten keine Schule
besuchen und von der Mitteilung der
deutschen Behörden dass die
Einreisepapiere plötzlich nichts mehr
wert sein sollen
vor zwei Monaten nach Iran kamen wurden
wir an der deutschen Botschaft
interviewt und haben die Visa erhalten
dann wurde unsere Mutter krank musste
ins Krankenhaus und wir konnten erst mal
nicht fliegen jetzt ist unsere große
Sorge dass unser iranisches Visum
ausläuft das auch unser deutsches Visum
ausläuft und dass wir vielleicht nach
Afghanistan zurück müssen
sie zeigen uns die Visa in den Pässen
gültig bis Anfang Mai droht dann der
Verfolgten Frauenrechtlerin und ihrer
Familie die Rückkehr ins Land der
Taliban
unsere Interview-Anfrage an Ministerin
Bär Bock wird nicht beantwortet auf
unsere schriftliche Frage ob es sich
hier um ein Missverständnis handelt
heißt es aus dem Auswärtigen Amt es
brauche neue Sicherheitsüberprüfungen
weil es Hinweise auf Missbrauch gegeben
hätte
bis zur Etablierung dieser
Sicherheitsmechanismen können erst
einmal keine einreisen nach Deutschland
von aufgenommenen afghanischen
Staatsangehörigen stattfinden
Matthias Lehnert ist Experte für
Aufenthaltsrecht das bereits
aufgenommene Schutzsuchende nicht mehr
nach Deutschland einreisen dürfen hält
er für rechtswidrig
an Visum das einmal erteilt wurde kann
nicht einfach mir nichts dir nichts
zurückgenommen werden ein Visum ist ein
Verwaltungsakt genauso wie eine
Baugenehmigung wo der Staat sich nicht
einfach hinstellen kann und sagen kann
aus welchen Gründen auch immer wir
nehmen das jetzt zurück sondern dafür
gibt es ein Verfahren ein festgelegtes
Verfahren in dem die Person angehört
werden und wenn die Bundesregierung sich
nicht an so einem Verfahren hält sondern
einfach aus
allgemeingültigen Gründen das Visum
zurückzieht dann begeht sie tatsächlich
einen Rechtsbruch ein Rechtsbruch vor
diesem Hintergrund in Afghanistan wird
das terror-receiver der Taliban täglich
brutaler
Frauen ist der Zugang zur Bildung
weitestgehend verwehrt ihre Rechte und
Freiheiten werden immer weiter
beschnitten
Kritiker des Regimes mit dem Tod bedroht
weil Deutschland keine Botschaft mehr
hier unterhält werden die ausreisen von
den deutschen Vertretungen in Iran und
Pakistan abgewickelt von dort schreibt
der deutsche Botschafter einen
Brandbrief nach Berlin darin heißt es
angeblich verfolgte Juristen sein gar
keine sondern Zitat
Absolventen von Koran Schulen geschult
in der Scharia im religiösen rechts und
Wertesystem das Islam
wir wollen wissen ob das der wahre Grund
für den einreisestopp ist und Fragen in
der Bundespressekonferenz den Sprecher
von Außenministerin baerbock es gab ja
einen Brief des Botschafters aus
Pakistan das da rein Weise Scharia
Richter nach Deutschland gekommen sein
wie sieht das nein das sind nicht
reihenweise Scharia Richter nach
Deutschland gekommen es ist richtig dass
es in den vergangenen Wochen vereinzelte
Hinweise auf mögliche
missbrauchsversuche gegeben hat es gab
in einzelnen Fällen unklare
Familienstrukturen es hat zum Beispiel
jemand eine Nichte als Tochter
ausgegeben eine Nichte als Tochter
ausgegeben dass allein deshalb ihr
Ministerium die Aufnahme von allen
Schutzsuchenden aus Afghanistan aussetzt
ist kaum nachvollziehbar hat sich doch
Anna-Lena bärbock eine feministische
Außenpolitik auf die Fahnen geschrieben
besonders den Schutz und die Stärkung
von Frauenrechten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die Opposition eine stallvorlage
serapühler ist migrationsexpertin der
CDU
wir reden über Frauen die dem Taliban
regime entkommen sind die deshalb ein
Visaantrag gestellt haben was passiert
mit diesen Frauen Frau berberkette die
Möglichkeit gehabt mit diesen Beispielen
indem sie wirklich Frauen die in Not
sind ihnen den Zugang nach Deutschland
gewährleistet ein Zeichen zu setzen was
sie mit feministischer Außenpolitik
meint und das ist hier leider nicht
gelungen
apropos gelingen das
bundesaufnahmeprogramm Afghanistan ist
ein Herzstück grüner Migrationspolitik
stolz verkündet im vergangenen Oktober
einen großen Erfolg den wir erzielen
konnten mit Blick auf Humanität ist das
Aufnahmeprogramm für Afghanistan das
heute vorgestellt wird vom
Innenministerium und von
Außenministerium
im Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel
vereinbart sollen jeden Monat 1000
schutzbedürftiger aus Afghanistan
geordnet nach Deutschland einreisen
dürfen bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode sollen so 40.000
afginnen und Afghanen ein sicheres zu
Hause finden
nach einem halben Jahr ist immerhin
Annalena bärbox presseprecher zufrieden
wir sind sehr stolz darauf dass wir
dieses Programm haben nur wie gesagt wir
müssen jetzt sicherstellen dass das
Programm den höchsten
Sicherheitsansprüchen genügt ist das
schon angelaufen ist es angelaufen in
dem Sinne dass bereits
Meldungen von gefährdeten Personen dort
eingespeist wurden es sind aber noch
keine Personen im Zuge dieses Verfahrens
nach Deutschland gekommen
keine einzige Person in sechs Monaten
Gerald Knaus ist einer der
renommiertesten migrationexperten
Europas und sieht angesichts dieser
Bilanz die Glaubwürdigkeit der
ampelregierung in Gefahr
es ist wirklich wichtig dass dieses
Programm jetzt schnell anläuft denn
ansonsten ist das eines der großen
Versprechen für legale Wege und eine
feministische humanitäre Außenpolitik
und Flüchtlingspolitik das darf nicht
scheitern in Berlin treffen wir Amira
die für Frauenrechtsorganisationen in
Afghanistan gearbeitet hat aus Angst um
die Familie in der Ferne will auch sie
unerkannt bleiben ihr ist die Flucht
gelungen bevor die Bundesregierung Stopp
gesagt hat
Fatima in Teheran ist ihre Schwägerin
damit ein Teil ihrer Familie noch immer
in Gefahr per videokäufer sucht sie die
Kinder zu beruhigen
Bananen natürlich verstehe ich wenn die
deutsche Regierung Sicherheitskontrollen
machen muss aber wie kann es sein dass
diejenigen die die Sicherheitskontrollen
schon bestanden haben jetzt nicht kommen
dürfen
so sitzen in Teheran mehrere hundert
geflüchtete wie Fatima und ihre Familie
fest meistens in Hotels warten darauf
dass neue das bessere Nachrichten aus
Deutschland kommen aus dem Land auf das
sie für eine sichere Zukunft gesetzt
hatten und dessen Regierung auf ihre
großen Worte bisher wenig Taten folgen
lässt